[Music]
this is some big sushi and if you're
hungry enough to eat this
there's a man you should meet another
young devil Amos the only original
nowadays
oh and he makes the smallest sushi too
[Music]
welcome to angio city in Japan home to a
small establishment with not so small
dishes hero mu has been making sushi
here for 44 years
[Music]
oh no yeah you know come on up you guys
I know like honestly she do I do
something one day a drunk customer
challenged hero mu to make the biggest
sushi roll he could so he whipped out
the seaweed and delivered who knows you
are my hero mu makes several infamous
giant sushi dishes who you know I'm away
I go
Barajas oh yes Angie go grey domicile
big sushi means big money he Romans
generous roll cost 146 US dollars
Lala dr. McNamara
that guy bought you this new life he
must that I know Lee ro Joon animal a
wicked shall be a mistake you gotta move
natal you know why you poor not have a
mistake Nick my goodness and what about
the surprise eel that Asami guy no akyuu
right
sorry guy insecure so I it's you know on
ago family mizuno-san you do ah but if
for eels sounds like a bit much here on
also has a plan for Dane tear eaters
amides you are yes and AH a very local
digital activities aquí ellos para
season upon dirty side totally hated
Kasumi
here Omer serves his mini sushi in a
matchbox
I saw me boku so look at not only us
Ichigo me doesn't it look at sometimes
they tell about whatever I never am one
is indifferent to our that our doctors
out there cuz I'm more month or that for
the Cucuy she's not there put an update
Davonte who hangs at all
[Music]